qualora quella intro che non avevo mai
fatto quella originale assisi è da tutti
ragazzi e pervenute che sono video sono
fa vj siamo arrivati ragazzi a 2 milioni
e mezzo di iscritti di è una roba è una
roba [ __ ] vi ringrazio i ragazzi per il
traguardo incredibile lo speciale
principale dei due milioni e mezzo di
iscritti
lo farò ragazzi al mio ritorno dal texas
kay vado in texas dal 6 all 11 aprile
ho deciso quindi di fare come primo
speciale la prova a non ridere challenge
premetto è una cosa che mi state
chiedendo di fare tutti quanti da una
vita e mezza non l'ho mai fatta perché
l'hanno fatta per i mente tutti cioè su
youtube l'hanno fatto da fata anche mia
nonna solo che ragazzi ultimamente ho
parlato con vegas dei match
ce l'hanno fatto anche loro facendo
questa challenge donano 10 euro ogni
volta che si ride perché la prova non
ridere challenge sta nel non ridere cioè
ti vien da ridere non devi ridere e
quindi per arricchire questo challenge
ha detto mica è una cosa stupenda
facciamo che unire l'utile al
dilettevole facciamo anche noi questa
cosa delle donazioni che è fantastica io
non l'ho mai fatto ragazzi quindi non so
non ho idea di come sei veramente così
difficile
grazie dell'ambulanza tempismo fiction
[Musica]
per quest'anno fare sul serio da datemi
in bus era o mio dio ginnaste came back
ma vuoi ma ma puoi sangue
no geniale
smack cruz alla madonna schifo forte
c'era ma uguale fiera messa reaction e
gas
oddio la geniale si sa chi cazzo era
bellissimo ma fermi poiché cazzo ma ma
vero da questa geniale ragazzi avrei
potuto ridere ma non l'ho fatto
sono una persona forte ma come
[Musica]
bellissimo voglio adottarlo
immediatamente
bruttissima oddio questo ritorno in
faccia oggi ha visto questa mi ricordo
dove l'avevo già vista addio oggi anche
questa volta mi la gta edition
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma che cazzo è appena sufficiente ma
perché la gente fa ste stronzate rai che
provata e vabbè cava che questa è morto
ma che cavolo sono micucci che questa
vale doppio ragazzi datemi un cazzo di
vuvuzela che mi scateno l'inferno
oddio lorenzo fragola caso questa idea
ok ma geniale non dovrà mai più cagare
nei bagni pubblici da solo incredibile
vabbè genio
no no non è vero ma per quale motivo ma
veramente doveva essere chiusi
deficienti oddio miley ma che
un'aragosta
[Musica]
facciamo tutti un minuto di silenzio
quali sputacchi che ci sono sul mio
monitor in questo istante accordo
ragazzi è stato più strano del previsto
perché dio mio non so quanto fatto di
risate quindi non azioni non ho idea
perchè devo ancora a montare il video
quando lo monterà ragazzi con te rode
quanto fatto poi avete già visto per i
soldi ricavati ragazzi ci sarà una
donazione e metterò lo screening in
descrizione ovviamente per giustificarla
è una challenge bellissima che dio mio
dovrà assolutamente rifare i ragazzi
conclude l'episodio è stato strano ma
parecchio strano però spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi che ha senso mi è
piaciuta lasciato sgomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e condivido
tante finzione sensori cities che
diavolo prossimo video ei ragazzi